what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and it looks like we are getting a
She-Hulk season two now this may come as
a big surprise to some fans maybe not to
some others I know there were a lot of
people out there who liked She-Hulk but
a lot of people out there who didn't
like She-Hulk but regardless of however
you feel it looks like She-Hulk season 2
is going to have a pretty decent impact
on the future of the MCU including
setting up multiple different projects
that fans I know are gonna be excited
about plus of course the two characters
we truly care about Madison and Wong
hopefully wongers and Madison come back
in season two I would be shocked if they
didn't and perhaps we could get another
Walk of Shame from another superhero or
maybe Daredevil does it again I am
expecting season two of She-Hulk to be
actually quite different than what we
saw for season one and for the people
who claim that She-Hulk season 1 wasn't
really that important I think season 2
is going to be quite important and of
course I'll explain why in this video
but if you're new be sure to subscribe
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest MCU news and there are only a few
days left in our giveaway all you got to
do to enter is subscribe and leave a
comment down below for a chance to win a
PS5 an Xbox series X some Marvel Legends
items or some DC items the winner picks
one item and we pick a winner at the end
of each month now also a really really
quick update about the Marvels Captain
Marvel 2. we have heard from multiple
insiders that Captain Marvel 2 or the
Marvels is only going to be 1 hour and
38 minutes long this originally came
from The Insider cryptic 4k qual on
Twitter who has reported very accurately
about trailers and run times in the past
then Insider can we get some toast came
out and said that they have heard the
same so it looks like the Marvels is
going to be under two hours this is
going to be one of the shorter Marvel
movies so let us know in the comments
does this concern you or do you think
that this is going to be fine it is
quite short Guardians of the Galaxy 3
was two and a half hours long and even
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania was 2
hours and five minutes long but let us
know your thoughts down below Marvel
also made a pretty cool announcement
yesterday that we'll talk about at the
end of this video but according to The
Insider my time to shine hello who has
an excellent track record with scoops
and leaks Etc we are going to be getting
a She-Hulk season 2. The Insider
specifically stated on Twitter today
She-Hulk season 2 is happening or should
I say will happen host strikes now in a
universe right now where Phase 5 and
Phase 6 are seemingly packed right now
tons of movies and shows coming out it
is very interesting that they would
choose to do a She-Hulk season 2 in the
midst of all of that and it makes you
wonder why is She-Hulk season 2
important enough to be thrown into an
already pretty jam-packed schedule for
Phase 5 or phase six and I think it's
because she Hulk season 2 will lead into
two really big movies one of course is
Avengers Kang Dynasty and the other is
World War Hulk now we've been hearing
for a while now that Kevin foggy wants
She-Hulk to be a new Avenger he wants
her on that roster sister and he is
Kevin feige the president of Marvel
Studios so she's gonna be on that roster
and the way my time to shine hello
tweeted it sounded like this is going to
be coming pretty soon possibly even in
Phase 5 or maybe in Phase 6 B4 the King
Dynasty comes out it sounds like this
project might be a priority for Marvel
Studios to get out sooner rather than
later and it makes sense if they are
trying to get her on that new Avengers
roster but they need a little bit more
story for her before they actually go
into the movie because remember Jen
didn't really want to be She-Hulk she
kind of just wanted to be a lawyer that
could keep her at this point in time
from just dropping everything and going
to help out the Avengers but with one
more season perhaps that's where she
could get to a place to where she could
be an Avenger and let's not forget two
very important links that she has to the
Avengers wongers and of course her
cousin Bruce Banner two direct links to
the new Avengers team we've heard Wong
is going to play a pretty important role
on the new team of course we do expect
Doctor Strange to play an important role
as well however Wong is the sorcerer's
Supreme at this point in time in the MCU
plus not to mention the plot of the King
Dynasty what is going to be at stake
here is pretty huge the stake of the
Multiverse I would assume that that is a
big enough reason for she hoped to get
involved if there is no Universe if
theirs gets destroyed by colliding into
another one due to an incursion then her
being a lawyer doesn't exist so I'm sure
after one more season of tying her into
other characters possibly and her
becoming more of a superhero not just a
lawyer who can be the Hulk sometimes but
more like a actual Hulk fighting crime
kind of like what we got with the
Daredevil episode I'm sure she'll be
ready to join the Avengers team but
speaking about her cousin Bruce Banner
we've heard for a while now that a new
Hulk movie is coming Marvel Studios
finally has the rights to do a solo Hulk
film and from what we've heard from the
Insiders this is going to be a World War
Hulk movie and from what we've kind of
heard about it so far it's really not
going to be 100 like the comics
storyline of world war Hulk which does
make sense we don't have the X-Men or
the Illuminati and the MCU yet a lot of
the storyline that kind of happens right
in the beginning of World War Hulk and
even before can't really happen in rmcu
plus not to mention Thor Ragnarok kind
of already did some of the world war
Hulk storyline with him becoming
Gladiator Hulk on sakar Plus in the
comics he believes that his son died
along with his wife but we already know
here in the MCU he has his son and he
has a son from sakar where he was at in
World War Hulk so it is going to be
different but from what we've heard
there are going to be multiple hulks in
World War Hulk and we know that a new
Hulk is coming to the MCU relatively
soon in Captain America 4 Brave New
World and that is red Hulk we also know
that the super soldier Serum is still
going to be a thing and Thaddeus
Thunderbolt Ross who is now played by
Harrison Ford is still going to
essentially run a super soldier program
so it looks like other hulks are going
to be coming as well so getting She-Hulk
involved in a world war Hulk film makes
sense plus not to mention Hulk's son
scar is a Hulk himself so I think we're
gonna have sort of a Hulk family for the
next Hulk movie we essentially have a
three Hulk team right now Bruce Banner
his cousin Jen and of course his son so
it kind of looks like the hulks are
going to be taking on a bunch of other
hulks which could be really really great
to see so overall looks like She-Hulk
season 2 is going to be setting up a lot
of future events but I do hope that
Daredevil comes back into the equation
especially since that probably means
that Daredevil will also be a part of
the new Avengers team but it does seem
like they have some sort of a
relationship it sounds like Jen is going
to end up in NYC so maybe they'll
explore that relationship further in the
MCU and maybe both of them will be on
the new Avengers team which I think a
lot of people will really like now as I
mentioned to end the video Marvel
Studios did have a pretty big really
cool announcement yesterday they have
announced the Marvel Cinematic Universe
an official timeline they released a
trailer for it yesterday on their
official YouTube channel and told us
what it was going to be about and they
say it's going to take every story every
movie every show every reference of
anything that's happened in the past
even if it hasn't been showed on screen
and they're gonna line it all up for us
and this is the first time that Marvel
Studios themselves are actually making
an official statement of this is it this
is the official timeline this is when
everything actually takes place time
wise in the MCU and there are going to
be a lot of really cool hidden details
that are going to add in this book as
well so be sure to check this out we're
also very curious to see what they say
about when Spider-Man homecoming takes
place as well as Doctor Strange most of
us have done the math and we know
exactly when it is but let's wait and
see what Marvel Studios has to say about
that it should be really cool and it
will be really great to get something
official from Marvel Studios so let us
know your thoughts about all of this
news in the comments down below what do
you think about a She-Hulk season 2 are
you excited are you going to watch it
are you going to pass on it are you
excited that it's going to lead into
other projects do you want Matt Murdoch
to return let us know all of your
thoughts in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you don't miss out on any
of the latest MCU news you can always
check us out on Instagram and Twitter as
well and as always thank you all so much
for watching
foreign